hey 42 here on the 26th of September
1983 in the midst of the Cold War a
russian colonel named stanislav petrov
was sat in the soviet missile control
center monitoring incoming satellite
data as he did every day his job was to
monitor the nuclear missile early
warning system and to report a suspected
launch higher up the command so they
could retaliate but on this day
something happened for the very first
time something he had been waiting for
yet dreading his entire career the alarm
sounded the early warning system had
detected that a nuclear missile had been
launched from the United States heading
towards the USSR then moments later more
warnings appeared five more missiles
have been launched by the US but Petrov
sat there and did nothing he didn't
report it higher up the commands like he
should have because he knew that would
mean a full-scale nuclear retaliation
from Russia and the end of the world as
we know it for he had a gut instinct he
felt that the computers were
malfunctioning and the warnings were no
more than false alarms he was right he
went on to help fix the bugs in the
system that caused the false alarm his
gut instinct saved the world and he has
lost come to be known as the man who
saved the world he received no reward
from the Soviets for his actions he was
in fact fired from his position and
reassigned to a less sensitive post
Petrov believes his superiors were
embarrassed about their failings within
the early warning system people often
tell you to trust your gut instinct but
what exactly does that mean do you ever
see someone and instantly get an uneasy
feeling in your stomach a little voice
inside you that says that person
up to no good when you're driving you
just know the person to the side of you
is going to suddenly change lane before
they have even begun to move the moment
right before something bad happens or
you receive bad news you get a sinking
feeling in your stomach a distressing
anxiety intenseness
well what if I said that this feeling is
caused by your second grade that's right
some experts believe that we have two
brains and one of them is in our stomach
now we're not talking about a
traditional brain here it certainly
doesn't look like one the brain and the
gut are intricately connected by a
network of neurons and nerves these
information superhighways transport
chemicals and hormones between our brain
and our stomach is how you know when
you're hungry your stomach simply tells
your brain this connection is called the
brain gut access but it's much more than
a connection between your brain and got
this chemical highway is part of a
larger network of hundreds of millions
of nerves and neurons cause the enteric
nervous system it monitors your entire
gastrointestinal system from the
esophagus all the way down to your anus
it reports back to the brain when we
should feel hungry Faulk when we're
nauseous and more but this is more than
just a fancy monitoring system research
has proven that the entire enteric
nervous system really can act as a
second brain so if you have two brains
you're going to need to feed them and
the best way to do that is by learning
incredible new skills from some of the
world's leading expert in their fields
Skillshare have helped up the channel by
supporting this video Skillshare is an
online learning community for creators
with more than 16,000 classes and design
photography film writing and so much
more
anyone can take a class or learn how to
start their next big project you can
take a class entirely at your own
and you can even teach a class yourself
if you like Premium Membership starts at
only $10 a month for unlimited access to
every class that's 16,000 opportunities
to learn incredible skills from industry
experts for the price of a couple of
coffees right now the first 500 people
to click the link in the description
will get a two month free trial or skill
show I have been completely immersing
myself in the incredible classes on
skill sure over the past few weeks
and I've learned so much I've even
picked up a couple of new techniques and
skills that should improve my videos so
I highly recommend it that really is
something on there for everyone so click
the link in the description the first
500 people will get a two month free
trial so how is it we have a second
brain well the enteric nervous system is
so complex and contains so many nodes
that it can act as a neural network and
process information exactly like our
brain does so your gut isn't just
reporting facts it's syncing them up to
now our second brain can't compose music
or help us out with our maths homework
but it can certainly think for itself
one area it excels in is hormones and
emotions the gut contains 95 percent of
the body's supply of serotonin a
neurotransmitter that affects our mood
it can make us happy sad anxious and an
array of other emotions the gut is
therefore hugely responsible for
controlling your mood happy guts
happy mind so much so that there is even
talk of a medication that directly
targets your gut as a potential cure for
depression but the key emotion here is
anxiety and it's how your gut can
predict the future and often make better
decisions about a situation and your
actual brain can the enteric nervous
system can make your brave feel anxiety
a drop of a house but it doesn't just do
it for fun our brain is constantly
taking in massive amounts of data and I
mean massive the brain processes 400
billion bits of information per second
the colors and shapes of every single
object in our surroundings every sound
we can hear the temperature what we're
going to say next 400 billion bits of
information at a time
sounds like superhuman levels of
cognition and it is because
unfortunately our conscious mind is only
aware of a measly 2,000 of these 400
billion bits of information that means
out of every 200 million bits of
information our brain takes in and
processes we only pay attention to one
of them it's why we experience tunnel
vision or single-mindedness although our
conscious mind doesn't make use of those
400 billion bits of information
our good does the enteric nervous system
and the brain can work together to
deduce things from the constant tidal
wave of ignored information and using
this collective information the brain
and the gut together can actually
predict the immediate future and if the
future looks somewhat uneasy our gut
immediately responds by making us feel
anxious
researchers in Colombia carried out
experiments and stumbled upon something
they called the emotional Oracle effect
over eight separate studies test
participants were asked to make
predictions on various topics such as
who will be the next US president which
movies will win awards will the Dow
Jones index go up or down and even the
weather some of the participants trusted
their initial gut feeling whilst others
made an educated and calculated guess
based on their knowledge 72% of people
who trusted their gut instinct predicted
that Barack Obama would preach Hillary
Clinton for the 2008 Democratic
SiC nomination whilst only 64% of people
who actually put thought into it made
the same correct prediction at the time
the two candidates were neck and neck in
the polls in fact the gut instinct
trusters were significantly better at
all the predictions than those who
fought about it logically they were 25%
better at predicting the Dow Jones index
and they could even predict the weather
with some degree of accuracy using
nothing more than what the enteric
nervous system was telling them but the
researchers found that this amazing
stomach powered predictive talent only
works if the individual has at least
some knowledge of the situation a gut
feeling doesn't work for things we know
absolutely nothing about suggesting that
the test participants weren't actually
predicting the future in a supernatural
sense what their enteric nervous system
and brain were collectively using their
aggregated knowledge to quickly form the
most accurate prediction possible based
on the information at hand all those
billions of bits of information we take
in each second are collectively
summarized and these summaries are sent
to our enteric nervous system which uses
it to determine which emotion we should
feel in across anxiety fear happiness
remember in school when the teacher left
the classroom for a few minutes and all
hell broke loose you could guarantee
that within five seconds someone will be
stood on top of a desk or drawing
phallic images on the chalkboard but
then suddenly you got a gut feeling that
the teacher was returning you couldn't
hear them but nevertheless out of
nowhere a wave of silence and obedience
would wash over the classroom in an
instant then sure enough the teacher
would walk in none the wiser it's almost
as if we predicted the future or I've
got did at least we may have had the
exact same experience at work too when
you're watching 42
YouTube and suddenly you sense that your
boss is walking down the hallway about
to enter the room and Rumble you so you
quickly hit the like button and close
your browser well this seems very
mystical it's not your brain on enteric
nervous system are actually using
billions of bits of data and past
knowledge to make an educated guess are
the typical behavioral patterns of your
teacher or boss whilst your conscious
mind is too distracted with whatever is
presently happening in front of you
perhaps your boss always comes and
checks on you around the same time each
day but you've never realized you don't
look at the clock but your unconscious
mind does and it has created a schedule
of your bosses daily actions and stored
it in the back of your brain without you
ever realizing it so it seems
Petrov's lack of action on that day he
saved the world wasn't random you may
not have known why at the time but there
will have been good reasons that his gut
decided to signal to him that something
was amiss with the alarm system
perhaps his unconscious brain had picked
up a few subtle signs from his
environment and passed knowledge that
the computers were malfunctioning and
petrov has later reflected back on the
events of that monumental day and he
himself said that at the time he had no
idea why he didn't report it to the
superious he just felt it was wrong he
couldn't explain why looking about now
he says there were definite reasons why
he should have suspected a false alarm
such as five or six missiles seemed like
an illogical first strike by the US
compared to America's total arsenal that
is a tiny number of missiles and if you
want to suppress your opponent's chances
of retaliation surely you would use your
full nuclear force against them up front
it's little things like this that
Petrov's guts will have picked up on
that day but his conscious mind
woodling hub so yes a man's stomach
really did save the world thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video then
please click here to support me on
patreon which really helps to support
the channel and you can get some cool
rewards like early access to all my
videos click here to watch another video
and if you haven't already don't forget
to subscribe also don't forget to check
out skill set by clicking the link in
the description